plan for this one david i think he'll be
quite direct and he starts with e4 the
kingsport opening and okay the sicilian
defense from magnus we never saw this in
the world championship match magnus
playing the sicilian every time there he
just played solid by replying with the
black king's pawn so now we will see
surely some world championship
preparation on the show look at the
pontiac he was just looking off to the
side there now looking down sipping his
tee he's just trying to remember what he
had planned for the world championship
match in this opening this is something
magnus rarely actually employs these
days pushing this pawn
usually we see him do something else but
uh yeah of course magnus has been here
before jan has also been here before and
okay jumping into the center with the
black knight
he played the same exactly the same
setup with the white pieces so uh he
often does this so he he goes to similar
uh kind of positions but moving the
knight in there is is the first kind of
unique idea i guess david okay and
what's he having for his dinner there
magnus it looks like some kind of
takeaway
is it noodles i don't think it's noodles
but it does look like maybe some kind of
asian cuisine uh meanwhile a trade of
knights in the centre of the board and
white's bishop getting kicked back
this is still relatively well known i
think black's bishop coming out
and this pawn push gaining time against
the black bishop black is struggling for
development as simon mentioned it's a
bit of a mirror image almost of the last
game between these two um magnus with
white was struggling to get his pieces
out now with black as well still a
couple of moves away from castling his
king take away it's just you know you
don't see that in any other sport i
think it must be uh some sort of other
esport
um mag nipomniachi's move where he
developed the knight to the side of the
board that was new i mean this is kind
of a little bit of a rare line
but that was new and uh now the players
are completely in new territory and uh
napoleon's plan is clear you know he
just wants to put pressure on that pawn
sitting in the central square and he
wants magnus to take a decision to kind
of exchange the pawns preferably thought
for magnus or okay he does play it i was
going to say he could back it up with
his knight just to defend this pawn but
there will be some consequences there
too uh
david i just wanted to put a question to
you and uh there we see white push up
his pawn i never played
the chess as we know it
i only played chess 960 and a variant
called king of the hill so chess 960 it
just teaches you a lot about pawn
structures where to put pieces it's all
about understanding rather than
memorization uh with the opening so yeah
i would love to play i'm not sure i
could compete with these guys
and wesley so of course the current
chess 960 world champion but i hope
there's another championship at some
point i think there's a world
championships in iceland 60 as well i
mean i think trying out these these
different games is uh actually quite
good for your chess i play this one
called free check yeah sometimes your
king actually travels five or six
squares rather than just uh in standard
chest the king starts in the middle and
it goes either two squares to the right
or two squares to the left in uh chess
960 and uh definitely i think one of the
variants of chess which will teach you
actually the most about general chess
understanding lots of crossover there
trying to get it all the way up the
board as far as it can go maybe to open
up the black king i mean that's a very
typical idea here if you can play it but
magnus has
obviously good development and a very
sound position so it's not going to be
easy to break through all of the pieces
want to occupy the same squares but here
it feels like black is the one with more
ideas i was going to say black can jump
in with the queen to one of these
squares he does that he could also jump
in with his knight to one of these
squares
black is very flexible with his rooks
that could infiltrate with his own rook
lots of ideas white maybe a bit more
stuck i think jan would love to press
and gain some advantage i think this is
a great move that jan's played and this
is why maybe the computer likes white uh
it's a kind of a normal move but we
talked about white's pawns be weaknesses
black's got this horrible pawn on the
queen side um on the dark square and i
think white's just trying to aim to take
that pawn and uh this this uh i quite
like white's position actually um
black knight has to mobilize it's not
really doing too much right now you
would want to normally bring it towards
the king side uh just as a defensive
piece and attacking piece okay magnus
does just push a pawn um i actually show
this on the board but pushing harry two
squares up i think i'm affected by you
simon i know i was i was wondering what
you're doing there it's like you know he
pushes it one square instead and the
evaluation bar does react it goes off in
white's favor david pointed out now so
uh and that is the obvious one the other
square was also i feel quite quite you
know quite tempting and uh magnus simply
retreating the queen so kind of
admitting that you know this queen foray
into the right side of the board didn't
work didn't work waste of time oh that's
a bad sign but black can always bring
the knight back i guess to defend but
it's very passive
okay now i i wanted to play this move
but i thought it lost the pawn because i
want to open up my bishop and go for
checkmate
that
what
does it lose i know because the queen
steps back ah okay this is really really
aggressive by janna ponichi he clearly
wants to win this game yeah he's going
on the attack now even though there's
been some trades he's going for it but
he's calculating right now can he get
away with it and he decides no he hasn't
played it wow he brings his rook into
the game but it feels like he's going
after a pawn which isn't too relevant
right now uh move the knight towards
black's could you be also quite clinical
as well can you just kind of go hang on
a second
my my position is overwhelmingly dark i
don't even need to do anything what's
this a blunder
i'm not sure about a blunder but a bit
of a strange one he brings his queen
across to attack the black knight so
white's queen on the diagonal hitting
the black knight but
the queen wanted to use a different path
into the position right
the white queen in the centre of the
board looked great okay that being said
black now has only one move to keep the
balance
and actually give himself the advantage
and that is not obvious right you can
take the pawn yeah maybe defend just
take in the center here calm defense and
rely on counter attacks
always this is why he's the world
champion i guess i mean knight g8 there
yeah i was about to say okay
the white knight could creep into the
position and uh utilizing some pins here
i'm not sure this fully works though
after for example black pushes with his
oh but then now there's a check maybe it
works oh this is this is crazy
crazy stuff coming towards the black
king it's all about the black king
either white is going to deliver
checkmate or he'll just be a pawn down
yeah for nothing i have to sacrifice
straight away maybe
you could try to bring the rook down
he's going for it going for the attack
he's all in right
yeah if this was poker he would his
chips would all be in the middle yeah
and uh yeah it's all about this
sacrifice trying to open up i mean i was
also thinking before you uh go for it
this might be a little bit slow but you
know we're gonna see it will he capture
that pawn on that hook on h6 now but now
it's going to pounce and this is
actually one checkmating pattern to
remember bishop he's played it wow
check and the king would move another
check and this would actually exactly
checkmate this pattern
the fishy wow it is completely crazy
this position now the knight cannot be
touched it's poisoned and look at this
you know the computer's suggesting moves
again it does suggest giving up the rook
for this bishop as we showed in that
line the bishop potentially strong but
then again black could go for queen
takes pawn that looks fine for black as
well i mean we've seen him play the best
moves several times already he's got
he's played the best move of course
very aggressive maybe unsound sacrifices
but magnus couldn't quite defend
properly uh in those ones but here this
is a lovely movie
just just bringing a piece over to
attack the queen and defend
then black will capture this white
knight and a quick material count shows
that black has a bishop and a knight for
one of the white rooks that's normally a
factor right now it's not about pawns
it's about pieces
black's knight and black's bishop
should be more powerful than one of the
white rooks and black's king for now at
least safe in the center
and yeah maybe for now for the first
time i start to agree with the
evaluation but that being said uh napoli
actually trying he's throwing all the
doesn't like going backwards does he he
likes going forwards and uh i mean why
not you've got to keep going once you do
an attack like this as soon as you start
defending it it normally goes horribly
wrong every position is every position
is full of poison i was going to
advocate for the second option greed
so i was going to say also this rook
move stops the black queen lining up
against this pawn meanwhile we do see a
couple of moves queen takes pawn was
played and after white's rook captured
attacking the black bishop the black
bishop now attacking the white rook and
white has to be a bit careful here this
theme has cropped up so many times in
this tournament the white king has no
breathing space so you have to be
careful later about lifting the white
rook off the first rank because later
there might be checkmating patterns
against the white king can he start
attacking very shortly we will yeah find
out yeah i mean okay he drops this brook
back attacking the black queen attacking
the bishop behind it black's queen has
to move and protect her bishop
and the opponent was with the one with
the rook and the queen knight bishop
combined for a deadly attack does he
need some air very urgently yes
and uh okay white's rook did move out of
the eyeline of the black bishop i think
if white gets an extra move we would see
harry the edge pawn just shuffle up one
or two squares just grab it grab it yeah
if he gets rid of that when he has done
if he gets rid of that pawn it does seem
like
okay you know black's
black's really going to be so
comfortable there um so there's no way
for white to defend the central pawn now
white central point
drop off but you know what you know what
you're doing desperate situations don't
you there's only one pawn you push in
every situation
in every situation yet push that man up
the board
cross your fingers
and just punt him yeah and he's going
he's off that's exactly what jan is
doing crossing his fingers now because
on material terms black is ahead and now
this knight jumping away from any attack
he's so confident in this position it's
only got under a minute now yeah i know
it's not easy he could be patient
so he's uh put his work on a protected
square this is good good strategy um
black does have some idea as well of
bringing his rook down to the first rank
trading off a set of rooks trying to get
through to the white king
if you can swap pieces here then black
maybe
uh pretty happy just because he has a
material advantage as that tweet says
this one heating up
very exciting game yeah really good game
this one and now deadly threat on the
board deadly bring the queen and
blocking the the black screen
route to the corner so he's running why
doesn't it work um
this one is super complicated right now
uh white has just taken a pawn and
black's king cannot run because now the
knight is under fire and actually
there's a seat down there's some huge
threats white's queen is trying to come
up to the top of the board and then the
black rook in the corner would be taken
you can check you can check
you can check take the knight you've got
the h pawn i think this has happened
before magnus even though the computer
says he's winning as soon as he gets bit
of pressure he he doesn't find the right
defense could is jan winning now i think
he might be winning also look that white
h pawn harry might decide this game
might become a queen doesn't does that
really surprise you ever
keeps since shouldn't really surprise
you jan has been reacting to this magnus
making a move with uh
with 50 seconds left on the clock i
think he just panicked maybe because the
clock situation he had to make a hasty
decision and it just wasn't the right
one i think maybe the black king could
have run in a different way and uh now
this check clears the path for that
white h pawn to continue matching up the
board and it might go back in black's
favor so white has to be careful now but
harry does advance and
is now back to being equal again because
the follow-up
the first one but after the white pawn
pushes maybe attacking the black queen
yeah what next that is the big question
uh maybe jan trying to look ahead
through a foreign
both sides playing with fire now both uh
both kings vulnerable he's got to find
something or he's just going to lose
one okay with two seconds on the clock
down okay and that's a silent draw offer
from magnus because now he's trying to
get the black queen across to track the
white king from behind but if the white
king steps back we've seen that position
before okay jan does not want the draw
playing for the wins playing for the win
good man wow and the bar is definitely
alive in this game yeah and that check
from the white queen was blocked by
black's knight i'm surprised by that one
black's knight pinning itself and now
the black knight cannot move on this
diagonal the black's pawn in the center
of the board can step down attacking the
white queen
whoa
what a move
he blocks this check with his queen and
the white queen now forced to the side
of the board are things turning suddenly
white has to look at that white queen
what is she doing behind her king
she's hiding normally the king should be
the one
and hiding any results possible and it
has been for the last 40 moves or
something it seems it's been a
very very tense this one very intensely
with the time situation yan
doesn't have a great deal of time either
here that looks like he does it
you can't look through you can't i mean
the guy is just fearless in this game
you've got to give them so much both of
them both of them yeah but i mean yang
turning down these draws and going for
it
really impressive it's incredible i've
i've never seen anyone be as brave
what's going on here you block with a
queen now your queen comes into the game
if you get the queens off you're winning
my white queen to a more a more
centralized square okay and um and i
just want to i just want to queen my
favorite pawn here yeah it's all about
harry will that pawn become a queen now
this is another check this time on the
diagonal diagonal queen checks are
always the most effective now white has
to choose a square for his king
which square is safe are you tempted to
run up the board super tempted
especially in light of what he's done
previously but now the king retreats and
black finally blocks this pin so black's
knight now is finally free to move the
white queen has to run away
and uh where is she going
queen trade would benefit white here for
sure he offers it going for the exchange
oh but the bar reacting again
i mean no
neither of these two players can relax
because there will be more twists and
turns ahead for sure it's so imbalanced
this one
miles away from a drawer this one should
end with a decisive result look at that
white pawn one square away from
promoting now does he have any
follow-throughs after the king steps
back
check again well there was actually only
one queen queen h3
wow
is is this uh
well is it is he going to go queen takes
brook and play two queens
black's queen under fire once she moves
white's pawn is about to promote but she
gives a check the white rook can block
magnus shaking his head and then i guess
black and he has played it i mean jan
really wants to win this this is the
only way to stop the h pawn as well it
will
eliminate that white pawn wow
okay where was he harriet
briefly briefly
before she was eliminated and now it's
still a creative position still all
results possible this is so reminiscent
of their game six from the world
championship match and the black king
can hide behind those pawns i mean often
your pawns are like your personal
bodyguards that's why you castle you
have your pawns in front of your king
but in these strange situations as well
you use those pawns to block the files
and uh this this pin that david pointed
out the on the white rook if white can't
get that rook into the game maybe i'm
starting to uh take magnus aside here
you know maybe i'm starting to think i
actually like black's position um the
pontiac might try and get the draw here
just by continuing to check the black
king he's shaking his head doesn't he
this is the sign this is a sign that
he's
i think a draw is quite fair here yeah
to be fair again i mean they've both had
their chances but we've seen that
she's playing for the win he's playing
for the win
wow
brave man magnus's head shake though was
relief he knows he's escaped the worst
the way they shake their head now
too many times already on the tour but i
love the way jan's going for it he could
have taken the draw in a position that
seems to me very dangerous for white
he's unpinned his rook the white king
temporarily safe so the white rook is
finally free to roam again gets careless
and moves away i i must admit i'm a
little bit concerned for nepal miyashi's
position because i think jan might have
uh might be taking it too far and get on
with the next game um i just have a
feeling both players have stopped caring
about the result they're both just
focused on the process trying to find
tricks for trying to keep the game going
as long as possible
i mean if white if if yang can get his
rook into the game with a with a timely
check then he does have two and he's
he's going for it so he's trying to you
know weave a net around the black king
it's still it again seems like um
black's king is actually weaker you know
now that the rook's in play
the black queen can't move without any
allowing any checks so the pawn has to
push but this pawn if it doesn't come
through and become a new queen itself
then it might just drop off the board so
it's impossible for humans to work out
this position i mean the computer's very
good with queens and queen checks but
for a human to to find the right check
it's really really hard is that i i was
thinking there was some nice tricks king
went to the dark square root g4 would
have won uh i think but okay i mean even
here
this this king is really walking
walking dangerously at the moment yeah
more checks yeah white's king went on an
adventure earlier then it kind of got
scared and ran away now black's king is
the one yeah going walkabouts is that
black king gonna run back to safety or
is it going to continue its journey is
going forward stepping forward again wow
i mean the bodyguard is the king the
bodyguard of the pawn or is the pawn in
the body of god of the king it seems
like
for on yan the advantage that yan's got
here is he's always got the draw because
there's no way that black king can light
from the truck hide from the check so
yang can always take a perpetual check
but can he do better and the only way
he's going to do better is to get that
rook again
into into a better position somehow
he has to do it with tempo right because
that black horn is so so advanced you
know it's two squares away from queening
i i wouldn't blame uh napoleshi for just
bailing out repeating moves
at some point he's got to surely he
can't he can't keep rolling the dice um
if the black king goes back now that
will be the second time we've seen this
position but can magnus play for the win
can magnus just kind of zigzag his king
towards the white king and kind of bring
his king the other way and then use the
black pawns shelter from the tracks he's
trying to play for the win
you can get mated here though i mean you
go queen v1 queen f1 queen f2 chip yeah
maybe we can show that david this if you
try and bring your queen around the
other way you actually get chipmated and
uh i i mean
this is
you know you okay let's run away oh no
hello check mate all of a sudden so it's
the death yeah
that is the kiss of death yeah yeah so
magnus has to be super careful but he is
the one playing for the when he could
have taken the draw by just putting the
black king back retreating it but no
he's coming in now also there are ideas
such as bringing the rook across sliding
it back with checkmate
this looks super scary i think if the
rook comes across black has to maybe
even sacrifice the queen and yeah or you
could capture here white's queen will
take and are these pawns quick enough i
think they are but
this one still probably just a boring
draw i mean if it ends in a boring
drawing are we going to see it
coming back to trap the black king i
think black has to give up the queen you
have to do this or you have to give a
check would he find it this time david
he will find it this time he's always
found it every other time i mean he has
to find it's the only move so you have
to i mean you have to find this move
otherwise you resign yeah if the queen
checks for example white's rook will
come back and block and actually still
check meeting ideas against 30 seconds
30 seconds go back to the players will
he find this move queen takes pawn on
this square this would save the game 22
is going quick
ticking down does he look nervous no the
magnus looks super calm i think he's
spotted that he can bail out with a draw
queen takes pawn he's looking for better
but he can't
this is just the draw isn't it well he's
still playing for more actually magnus
yeah i mean he's kingy too he's like
okay he's still trying to win this
position so the reason we think it will
be a draw is because one of the black
pawns will cost white his rook
and uh one of the other black pawns will
just drop off the board so white's rook
does have time to go and win both of the
black pawns but will have to give itself
up in the process especially that black
d-pawn is two squares away from
promoting the only way to stop it is to
give up your rook this this to me is
like one of the games not just of uh um
the knockout stages but of the
tournament it's been so it's been so up
and down i mean it might not be the best
game according to the computer but for
drama it's been great because they've
both missed wins they've both been
attacking they've both turned down draws
it's got everything uh that you'd want
in a game this is going to look good on
the fighting chats index i was about to
say the same car their fighting index
scores are going to go through the roof
after this game and uh yeah i mean fair
play to both players now the game will i
think finally reach its conclusion we
saw a couple of checks from white but no
progress to be made black's pawn just
simply too strong but he has to keep
checking otherwise black will win and uh
here we go we're about to see
the second draw of the final
dramatic draw it's been i bet you they
both shake their head right you know
when when they when they had the draw
they i bet you they both like oh no
that's it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
we just want to see if we will will
magnus shake his head give us a head
shake magnus
probably no the yarn is definitely